do you ever check for that blue check
mark in your Gmail inbox well you might
want to start being a little more
cautious the new Gmail sender
verification system which highlights
verified companies and organizations
with a blue check mark has been hacked
by scammers cyber security engineer
Chris Plummer discovered that scammers
found a way to convince Gmail that their
fake brands are legitimate thereby using
the confidence the check mark system is
supposed to instill against Gmail users
what did Google do I reported the issue
to Google who initially dismissed its
intended Behavior after taking a closer
look we realized that this indeed
doesn't seem like a generic SPF
vulnerability later we recognized it as
a floor and listed it as a top priority
fix until Google resolves the issue stay
vigilant and double check the sender's
legitimacy when you see that blue check
mark be safe
[Music]